[Music]
we are still in sunny Los Angeles we're
gonna talk about if post Malone is
cursed by the babadook we're gonna talk
about
Elon Musk selling a party bus to the
moon but first roll this video this is a
duck hunt video showing that if you have
a player to controller you control the
duck so there's the duck we're all
familiar with to be human is taking it
to the upper corner it's actually like
like sat on the right oh there's the dog
this is in the Twitter zeitgeist because
seth rogen tweeted out about it show
that tweet and evidently this is just
blowing everyone's mind this trick is
decades old but I guess no one knew it
some people are happy a lot of people
are sad they're saying that's ruining
their childhood that they didn't know
this at the time when they play it how
do we feel it feels like a real life
like thriller where you're like it was
in front of me the whole I had no idea I
had no idea I also just AM like
adamantly opposed to people saying
that's something that they learned later
or that has changed ruin their childhood
your childhood was gonna be ruin no
matter what it was ruined just deal with
it and you learn something new and now
you're ruining your adulthood oh no I
knew about this I thought it was common
knowledge I mean due to arguments from
the family we somebody one day somebody
picked up the second controls yeah my
brothers do wonder what was a diggity
picked up the controllers like that and
there's a go I'm moving the duck that's
how it happened the dog is cool because
you don't know if he's laughing at you
or kind of encouraging you and I think
for me personally it's prepared me like
greatly to be friends with Hannah for
instance blow all your minds right now
because did you know that ghosts are
real it's true babadook goes there's a
video that you can look it up he was in
like a haunted house of some sort and he
touched a box
now he's cursed well he didn't even
touch the box he touched the guy who was
touching the box the transitive power of
curses it was a bad and so what has
happened to him since touching it he his
private jet blame the wheels blew out
right it's your private jet fancy car
almost got or got t-boned his fancy
house got robbed okay so so much bad
luck it seems like the only explanation
is some sort of final destination type
scenario where like death itself is out
to get posted my left eye six months
after college I thought I was cursed and
then I realized I was just mixing my
pills wrong maybe his demons are Bud
Light and xanax that's what he's always
on right you said you don't believe in
ghosts or anything but you believe in
curses
I believe it Gus I will even goes on the
off chance that they might be real yeah
you know I mean like no I don't really
but I do because I don't want to be on
them it's like a layer of protection for
yourself we want to talk about Elon Musk
and specifically the first commercial
trip to the moon has been purchased by a
Japanese billionaire by the name of
yuusaku Misawa he has this online
clothing company where he's got all this
money he's buying paintings he's doing
stuff like this it sounds like it's
gonna be a party bus to the moon because
he bought out the whole thing it's six
to eight people flying around the moon
him and his buds what's it gonna be
it's gonna be artists so he's only gonna
fill the plane with artists of his
choose it sounded like he just wants to
meet a bunch of famous people so he
rented out this bus so that he could be
like oh I really want to meet guys on a
regular flight but according to the
rules I'm pretty sure to get the space
you're gonna have to at least a bucket
in at least I think there's gonna be
some rules on this I don't know if
they're gonna be giving out cocktails on
the space flight
I'm sure there's gonna be like a space
flight attendant but I only thought
about this guy buying the first tourist
flight to the moon is that he should
have bought the second yeah to the moon
the first flight buddy no wait a minute
typically he's gonna take the greatest
artists of our time and just we're gonna
lose them all Fred Durst is going to be
on there mr. misawa if you're looking
for someone with a space material as
long as he doesn't bring post Malone I
think he'll be all right what's the
first thing you would do on the moon
space rocks all right I've seen space I
will say and I'll send you my prayers
what why do you wanna the moon why do
you want to go to the moon I can tell
she didn't expect that bus would be the
thing that would tear us apart and it
would be something eventually but I
didn't know be the space bus let us know
in the comments if you think you would
want to go to the moon we're going to do
something different right now
[Music]
what is up every damn day as we are in
Hollywood taking on the LA weed
challenge we are smoking out ten of LA's
most iconic landmarks
yeah we're smoking that New York City
dunk so we can handle your ass
government-regulated weed we're gonna
Runyon Canyon the Hollywood Walk of Fame
look Brea Tar Pits the Chinese Theatre
Santa Monica Pier Rodeo Drive Universal
Studios Orlando Florida and Venice Beach
with its observatory the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery rest in peace maybe ten
more who knows we're clearly at the top
of Runyon Canyon
[Music]
where to live the Brea Tar Pits
wait is okay
[Music]
what do you think Ari
haha they do this all ice cream here
[Music]
is there like a good part to this place
or what what kind of plants are these
student Hannah's acting weird dude I'm
over this LaBrea is Spanish for the tar
so these are the Tar Pits
[Music]
all right everybody that was the LA we
challenged you first you made it to all
10 locations probably more whoo hey this
is LA edition of learning and burn and
I'm Ryan Beck and today this is the
segment of course where I eat something
very hot and then I try to learn
something it's about 105 degrees under
the TV lights on the roof here and we're
gonna see how hot a person get before
they their pants in front of their
co-workers with me as always is real
life doctor of sociology Nate nirn PhD
thanks Ryan
how this is gonna work we're going to
have Ryan read a statement on a card
about the topic that he must learn he
then must answer a series of questions
correctly on that topic before he has
given the sweet relief of that glass of
milk Ryan are you ready no I'm actually
not this is a I this is I don't want to
do this today gray this is gonna be fun
today is burn is scotch bonnet Scoville
rating of 400,000 and today's learn is
what doesn't even mean it means it's
gonna be spicy today's learning is the
San Andreas Fault Ryan please get the
pepper Thank You Natasha the pepper is
the scotch bonnet oh yeah get those
seeds get those seeds what smell it I
got a whiff ago I love when you get a
whiff of it here is your card please
read for the camera the San Andreas
Fault is the 750 mile fault line
California oh I got another with oh my
god tectonic boundary between the
Pacific plate in the North American
plate and his motion his right-lateral
strike-slip according to a US Geological
Survey earthquakes happen along default
every 100 years while the last major
earthquake according to 160 years ago
suggesting Los Angeles could be overdue
for another magnitude 7.8 earthquake
could cause 2,000 deaths and over - and
over 200 billion dollars in damage Ryan
nice work first
question initial thoughts
earthquakes are bad correct next
question in a way that a grandpa would
understand what is the San Andreas Fault
it's a I noticed Earth's plates they
where they meet is a fault the tectonic
plates in the Earth's covered like a
beat to go like a pie I am taking it
away not right it's the crush is broken
up and they touch and then their
mountains and they move I really more
questions before you get that milk buddy
a seismograph is a device that measures
the intensity of earthquakes how do you
spell seismograph Ryan som nope
so close seismograph SM oh yes
the Scoville scale rates spiciness not
there yet
how many Scoville units would you guess
the scotch bonnet pepper it is I said it
a few minutes ago 400 million no four
hundred thousand that's right last
question the big one refers to a
hypothetical 8.0 earthquake in Los
Angeles which would destroy hundreds of
thousands of buildings the big one is
also a pretty funny nickname for a penis
Ryan was the nickname of your penis
here's Johnny how did that one compared
to the habanero it's a it's a kind of
the seeds are really bad
that was a mix between over but it this
is really a good job okay this has been
every damn day please like comment and
subscribe we'll see you next time good
job buddy you do this
[Music]